you guys go and make this tiny movie
called batman begins
um which i mean i think people
somewhat forget how radical that movie
was
in terms of reinventing the comic book
genre and how you could approach
um comic books because it was such a
grounded realistic
gritty approach to this kind of thing
you know not without humor but
um it was kind of leaving behind the
aesthetic of the tim burton and joel
schubacher films
um what were those conver those early
conversations you were having with chris
because it
again we take for granted now that like
oh you know the gotham city of batman
begins but it didn't exist
until you guys got together and came up
with it i remember when chris
chris said you know i went around to his
house
for lunch um and
uh chris uh you know he started talking
about like
he wanted to remake batman and
you know at the time it was like wow you
know
you know hasn't everything been done um
and and then he sort of slowly started
explaining to me what he wanted to do
and um i remember after that lunch he
sort of
he was just sort of he he got me very
excited and he was saying well
you know one of the biggest things he
wanted to try and do was
you know redesign the batmobile and uh i
remember
he he you know he specifically talked to
me so i went away
it was a friday i went away um
uh and i went down to toys r us
and bought a bunch of
vehicles and went over to my workshop
and cut everything up and smashed them
up and
i thought well you know we talked about
mixing a lamborghini with a humvee
and you know so that's exactly what i
thought well let's just start
somewhere and so we smashed this thing
together
oh i did and i left it on his doorstep
on monday morning and then uh
he called me and then we he said of
course we've gotta
get in here let's um let's convert my
two-car
garage into a workshop art department
and figure out how we're gonna do this
film and you know his thing was like
i gotta explain everything i've got to
explain
why batman is batman and why all these
things
these things don't magically work he
doesn't have any super powers he's just
he's he's physical and he has technology
and he has his
he is money his money is his super power
so we really just
started from from that moment and jonah
was there
chris's brother uh you know helping as
well
and uh so we just decided to take the
banner build
just as something to start with that
might inform the rest of the film
so that's really where when we often you
read about over garage
and that's kind of where that art room
started was like we just got to get
going and somehow we got to work it out
we had sort of
we had a bit of time more time than we
have on most films now we have like
three months
to try and figure out what the film was
and i think
you know again chris wanted some visual
help
you know he had these ideas he had this
uh scripture he's a very visual person
uh and he loves making models and stuff
i think you can draw and stuff so
we worked together in that art in that
garage so i think it was really about
trying to define every single element
and then trying to figure out
how this thing linked together i think
it holds up tremendously well and it's
really striking and
you know at the time it felt um kind of
momentous
and i don't think we expected that you
guys would one-up it
so significantly with the dark knight um
which at once feels you know uh part of
a whole it feels in
in step with batman begins but um
you know that that film is very much
inspired by heat and
it feels like gotham city is very much a
character in that film what was
what was kind of your guys's approach
going into that one because i i mean
most people now hold that up as one of
the best comic
movies ever made i think for me
i don't think it's true for chris darnay
is actually the batman i always wanted
to make but we
had to step over batman begins to get to
it
yeah and uh you know i'm uh you know
desperate modernist i like simplicity
you know gotham you know on batman
begins you know i struggled with trying
to
you know to make sure we didn't
uh destroy the comic book unless i guess
that if that's a word of of what batman
was and we tried to explain everything
in the cave
and that was under a way manner and how
that worked how you got down to it you
know
so there was a sort of loss of
explanation in the design
and i feel and i'm very grateful for
chris because he burnt everything down
batman begins yeah my manner didn't
exist
but therefore the batcave didn't exist
so it allowed me
and on batman begins we we pushed and
pushed and pushed to shoot
uh some of it in chicago chris has grown
up park
partly in chicago his mom's from chicago
so we had this sort of
lower weka drive we had a taste of
chicago and chicago obviously is
where modern architect architecture
it's just sort of it's it's it's not his
birthplace but it's where it continued
you know where you know house when where
all the great architects
who couldn't build new york went to
chicago who's got this
amazing architecture so we knew we knew
what we were going to do
uh if we got the chance to make a second
film and then the fact that
uh chris and jonah wrote to burn
everything
and david obviously um was
uh uh fantastic for me because then i
could say okay he lives downtown you
know
we're we're dealing with harvey dent
we're dealing with government
where government is like federal
buildings you know it can be
this sort of vision uh of
you know it has a hangover from the 60s
for me
um and then so that's where it led and
then the bat bunker obviously
uh was one of my favorite things to do
and actually one of the simplest sets
i've ever built so
oh yeah yeah uh i i mean one of the
i was there opening night and there were
a few moments where the crowd
you know was electric but one of the
biggest cheers i've ever heard in the
theater is when the batmobile explodes
and the bike
shoots out um was that was that on you
to figure out how
that all fit inside the batmobile and
could come out
that was actually a warner brothers um
executive
uh in early garage times uh
saying um uh hey
you know the bike could come out of the
car and we sort of they might have even
been on um
uh on batman begins i remember we kind
of just like
you know it sort of came back to us and
i think um
you know it was it was like oh yeah you
know
i think they're right we have to pull
the bike out of the car and um
you know so then it became this sort of
secrecy of like we couldn't say
there was you know a bike in it and we
you know we he has to sacrifice the
batmobile
um you know and we have to the phoenix
has to arrive
in the form of a bike and so i remember
we were very much in secret building
that thing
uh and there was no point modeling it
right because we like to use models and
you know play with things because it was
like it was like oh we might as well
just go to home depot and buy some parts
and build it full-sized model
and then so we sort of snuck up the
warning brothers and nicked the tires
off the batmobile
and brought them back to the garage but
we couldn't tell anyone why we were
doing it
and these were in the days when i could
go to home depot with chris and no one
would recognize him like chris you're
going to find the
you go and find some plastic pipe i'm
going to do this so we sort of divvied
it up and then we go to the plastic
store and
like that those days have gone i can't
take him anywhere
nothing done but um but yeah
so i mean that moment of
him destroying the batmobile or the
joker i mean
you know the game is on i i i agree with
him in fact my favorite moment
is is when the bike is going up up a
whacker at high speed and there's this
sort of
momentous speech at the end of the film
yeah
that film is uh is brilliant and
obviously heath ledger's
performance is just absolutely iconic
and and tremendous
um and i know chris had said he you know
he tackled each film at a time
but was there uh i know there have been
rumors that there was talk of bringing
the joker back for a third batman if
chris was going to make it was that
were you privy to the conversation about
that i think that i mean i'm there from
very early on there was nothing on
batman begins
yeah that conversation um you know the e
you know i think they need to stand as
individual films
i mean visually they are all three are
very
different you know they are i mean if
you look at them back the difference
between batman begins and the dark
knight
is like you know is is immense and then
then we went back to this sort of raja
ghoul
area you know where and then i i think
once we discovered
because we shot most of dark knight in
chicago then we
you know did this the interior sets in
uh
in london in an old airship hangar and
which we ended up keeping for
10 years or something and then dark
knight we you know in between
what we've done is we did we've done
these films in between the batman films
like the prestige got slotted in there
and we sort of you know that was very
low budget so we we sort of slowly
discovered
the beauty and advantage to getting
around locations and getting as many as
possible
so by the time we get to uh the dark
knight rises
we're going to like three different
countries you know so
and i think um you know and that really
expands the scope of the film uh
practically obviously we we make films
practically we
um we avoid set extensions and as much
digital work as possible
uh obviously it's in there because it
has to be in there but we try and not
we don't give over to it until we cut we
only do it when we have to
so and that the question of when you
have to is different for all people
yeah for us it's like
it really really has to be an
impossibility
yeah when you say i mean the dark knight
you
finally got to really showcase chicago
um
but coming to the darknet rises it feels
different and just absolutely epic um
what was that challenge like for you to
come in
for a third one and now make it feel
visually distinct from those other two
films
well we'd always you know batman begins
uh myself and chris you know uh i mean i
live in
brooklyn so we always he'd come over
here he'd just often come and write in
new york
uh i won't tell you where uh and
um i get a phone call and so we again we
go walking we walk the city
and talk about what if gotham was here
you know like
you know what if the film was here so we
always talked about new york but never
never um never shot in new york
because chicago it's hard to shoot here
and on to close down
the kind of areas we would need to close
down it it's very difficult
so we always talked about you know we
play the film here and then we go to
chicago
which we both know and then i think um
by time we got to darling rises it was
like
kind of have to film in new york so
i mean we kind of have to go if we're
going to do it we have to actually
finally play gotham as new york um uh
because on batman began begins we walk
around downtown
uh and and say okay imagine if gotham
was here like
let's talk about how it could be here
and really that informed the prestige
because we shot the whole of prestige
downtown
even though it's victorian london so you
know so one
often these things these ideas sort of
flow and weave
and we sort of you come back to stuff
that maybe isn't right
for one thing that you remember it or
you know the age old thing is we scout
the next one when we find all the
locations for the last